let's talk about the International
Criminal Court and why the u.s. is going
after the ICC is investigating whether
war crimes were committed in Afghanistan
[Music]
not just by the Taliban and Afghan
forces but by the US military to u.s.
President Donald Trump responded by
imposing sanctions on ICC prosecutors
you cannot we will not stand by as our
people are threatened by a kangaroo
court so why is the u.s. lashing out at
the ICC what happened in Afghanistan and
what if anything has Israel got to do
with any of this
[Music]
let's get our heads around this business
of international justice the ICC is
there to hold the most powerful people
accountable for the most serious of
crimes it's about providing millions of
victims with access to justice if the
country in question is unable or
unwilling to seek it for them that's why
it's considered the court of last resort
it's people like there were Hingham
Muslims they were forced to flee a
military crackdown in Myanmar there's
also the Yazidis in northern Iraq
brutalized and enslaved by Islamic state
fighters and the people of Darfur and
Sudan who say they were subjected to a
campaign of terror by government backed
militia the ICC was created in 1998 by a
treaty called the Rome Statute most
countries in the world have signed on to
it and the court works like most courts
the prosecutor builds a case and takes
it to trial and the accused has the
right to appeal now a person can be
investigated if they're accused of
committing crimes in any of the 123
member countries Afghanistan is one of
them prosecutors can also investigate
people from countries that aren't signed
up to the ICC like the u.s. that's why
Americans are being investigated for
what happened in Afghanistan the UN
Security Council can also refer cases to
the court like they did with Darfur
even though Saddam isn't a member now
the United States of course is not a
state party to the Rome Statute and that
is completely their decision that's
their sovereign right but it doesn't
exempt United States citizens from ICC
jurisdiction when crimes are committed
on the territory of the state party
among other places the ICC is now
looking into atrocities in Afghanistan
the case has focused on events after
2003 and alleged crimes by all sides
let's start with the Taliban
in 2001 the Taliban was in power they
were seen as an oppressive regime that
refused to hand over Osama bin Laden
after the September 11 attacks the u.s.
went into Afghanistan to push them out
by 2003 a new Afghan government was in
place and the US and NATO had control of
the military but Taliban fighters didn't
go away they and other militant groups
went on to wage a guerilla war not only
targeting Afghan forces and their NATO
allies but civilians too and the
violence hasn't stopped there are
attacks nearly every day in many parts
of Afghanistan the ICC is also looking
at Afghan forces and whether they
committed war crimes on a list of
accusations torture and sexual abuse of
detainees the court has its sights on
people like General Abdul Rashid Dostum
who until recently was Afghanistan's
vice-president during the war he led a
pro-government militia whose fighters
are accused of atrocities like killing
and burying thousands of Taliban
prisoners and mass graves at the time
his militia was backed by US Special
Forces
that's them writing with general
Dawson's men which brings us to the
United States and what it stands accused
of for nearly 13 years Americans were
the major foreign power in Afghanistan
leading an international coalition that
at one point in 2010 reached a hundred
and fifty thousand foreign soldiers US
Special Forces were mainly there to
support the Afghan government but
they're accused of crimes including the
abuse of prisoners and covering up
killings
we are talking about use forces in my
downward AK D were abducting people
torturing them killing them disclosing
their bodies keeping their body parts as
trophies during the night raids they use
special forces a storm in a place we are
celebrating the birth of a child and
Gabby's profits and they try to cover it
up
bullets out of the bodies of the dead
the CIA is also being investigated for
its use of torture ghoul was beaten and
doused in cold water by CIA
interrogators he was left chained to the
floor of his cell half naked in the
morning cool rock man was found dead
so the prosecutor's office at the ICC
gathered all of this evidence on
Afghanistan and finally got the green
light in March to go ahead and then
President Donald Trump imposed sanctions
something the u.s. usually reserves for
rogue nations and human rights abusers
they include travel bans and asset
freezes against the office of the
prosecutor the United States seems to be
afraid of the ICC because if you're not
afraid of something why take such an
extreme reaction against it but
resisting the ICC's jurisdiction seems
to have been US policy from the
beginning the Clinton administration
only reluctantly signed the Rome Statute
and two years later President George W
Bush withdrew from it you know as the
United States works to bring peace
around the world our diplomats and or
soldiers can be drug into this court
that's very troubling to me the u.s.
then took more steps to protect itself
in 2002 during the Bush era they passed
a law that allows the us to ignore the
ICC it even authorizes the use of
military force to free US Nationals
detained by or on behalf of the court
and yet the US has been known to
cooperate with the ICC let's not forget
that Dominic ongwen
was delivered to the court with the
assistance of the US government the
United States co-sponsored the referral
of Libya to the ICC the United States
advocated for a referral
Syria but there's another factor at play
here and that's Israel it's one of
America's closest allies and is also
being investigated for suspected war
crimes in Palestine like the u.s. Israel
isn't an ICC member but Palestine is so
in 2018 the United States says Security
Advisor John Bolton said that the
Palestinian Liberation Organization
offices would be closed in Washington
basically has a penalty for pursuing
this investigation against Israel in
fact earlier this year Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu called for
sanctions against the court and he got
what he wanted first I want to
congratulate President Trump and
secretary Pompeo for their bold
leadership and sanctioning the corrupt
and biased International Criminal Court
the ICC fabricates outlandish charges
against Israel shame on them the only
way that countries can avoid ICC
prosecution is if they're investigating
themselves that's what the afghan
government says it's doing but many in
afghanistan don't trust their own
justice system because of the whole
weakness of the afghan government not
having an independent judiciary and lack
of capacity the u.s. says it's already
investigated its military that happened
under President Barack Obama the u.s.
reported over 600 different
investigations over 250 individuals that
were held to account and punished in
some way for allegations or for abuses
of a prisoners that were found to be
credible and sustained but the court
says those investigations haven't gone
far enough
international justice is a tricky
business the courts been accused of
targeting mostly African suspects
countries are pulling out to avoid being
investigated and the ICC has no way of
enforcing its decisions
it relies on countries to cooperate and
hand people over and then there's its
record in 18 years it's convicted four
people but these are powerful people
like the Congolese warlord Thomas
Lubanga he was convicted of war crimes
for recruiting child soldiers and the
Bosnian Serb military commander Rocco
melodic for this revenue to genocide and
other crimes for all its successes and
perceived failings the ICC is still seen
by many as important and necessary just
as people in Afghanistan we know and we
are fully aware that it will not be
perfect
ivana son has been suffering for the
past 50 years and when people have never
had any chance of justice and
accountability and for that reason ICC
is the last resort it should be able to
break that vicious cycle of impunity in
Afghanistan and bring some sorts of
accountability to us
so are those US sanctions going to work
well the ICC says it will carry on doing
what it's doing which is sort of its job
to act independently and resist the most
powerful no matter who they are
if there's a news story you want us to
explain OnStar here get in touch with us
on Twitter or Facebook and make sure to
subscribe to al-jazeera on YouTube so
you're up to date with all of our
episodes I'll see you next week
you
[Music]